why didn't you make me do that
look at me focus on my voice I'm not
giving up on you team she was my friend
you're my family James no matter what
look
you're special gene and if you stop
fighting that force inside you
whew Grayson
he will possess the very power of a God
she'll kill us all tell me how we fix
this trough tell me what to do now don't
know what to do
no they don't understand they fear and
what they fear we seek to destroy
it's your fault Charles
my eyes to protect Tara I'm scared
when I lose control bad things happen to
people i watch the girl dies she's still
Jean one can still help her
sometimes you want to believe people as
something that they are not
no determine Venus who they are it's too
late
she's coming
hey everybody its charlie we got a new
x-men Dark Phoenix trailer surprise
super late at night but this is just
hyping up how powerful she is and
Jessica Chastain's alien character
trying to turn jean grey against the
x-men sort of filling in a couple of
roles from the comic book version of the
Dark Phoenix saga so we'll break it down
there's a new round of the imax ticket
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave your favorite
Dark Phoenix moment on the video even if
it's from the animated series or the
comics so they finally confirmed that
Jessica Chastain is playing an alien
character when I first heard she was
going to be cast I assumed that she was
going to be playing Alondra but then
they said that she'd be playing the
villain so because she's confirmed alien
in all the Shiar canon from the comics
in the Dark Phoenix comic book story
something they haven't even gotten close
to in any of these x-men movies before
she says that she feels like she's doing
a good thing in trying to use the power
of the Phoenix by co-opting Jean Grey
trying to take it for herself back to
wherever her planet is I'm assuming that
if she's not playing Landreth at she's
playing death bird her sister keep in
mind that they're both telepaths that
would explain why she the villain is
also a telepath because the lander is so
powerful that she can contact Charles
Xavier across time and space the other
thing about their race is they also look
humanoid so it's not like she's a scroll
or something like that there were early
rumors that she could be playing a
scroll but because the MCU the Captain
Marvel movie in Avengers endgame
possibly are writing so hard on Scrolls
it's just unlikely that they would also
try to do it in the Fox movies at the
same time but the scene at the beginning
may seem familiar they're actually doing
a funny thing here where it's sort of a
dark twist on the x-men last stand scene
where Professor X and Magneto younger
versions of them go to meet a young Jean
Grey and look at her powers and things
start to go crazy and he has to calm her
down so then you remember later in that
movie spoiler alert for x-men Last Stand
if you haven't seen that yet she winds
up killing Professor X as an adult when
her powers go off the chain and she
gives in to the Phoenix force and
becomes full-blown Dark Phoenix the way
that she killed him was also important
too because there's some visual
references because it's kind of
happening in the background of this shot
- she disintegrated professor X she was
so powerful the house around her started
to disintegrate - so you look here and
it's actually magneto that she's using
her power
on in the way they let you know how
powerful the Phoenix force is is that
our telepathic attacks are able to
penetrate Magneto's helmet which is
designed to thwart telepaths like
Professor X most powerful telepath on
earth can't get through that helmet but
the Phoenix force is so opie that it can
break right through so that's why it
looks like Magneto's eyes were getting
ready to pop out of his skull he's being
subjected to so much psychic force I
love the look on Jessica Chastain in the
background here too she's just watching
it all very casual like this is just
another day for her no big deal we'll
just pop both of their skulls and go on
our merry way off the planet so I can
take you back and use you for myself the
rest of the trailer just sort of gives
you the origin story it is basically a
better version of x-men Last Stand you
get Jean Grey's back story about how she
accidentally killed her family she
didn't know how to control her abilities
so Professor X puts something of a
psychic block to make her forget about
all that then they do the comic book
origin story where do they go into outer
space in the Phoenix force enters her
and that's when her full-blown abilities
start to become unlocked again so even
before she got the Phoenix force Jean
Grey was an omega-level mutant afraid of
her abilities because she seemingly
wasn't able to control them and hurt
people around her the Phoenix force
itself and Jessica Chastain's villain
here are sort of the devil on her
shoulder whispering just unleash your
fury show them how powerful you are
don't hold back it looks like they tuned
up a lot of the special effects
particularly the space scene where she's
getting her powers so the interesting
thing here too is because she's in the
vacuum of space
surviving while this is happening how
they explained them getting back to
Planet Earth in one piece like maybe she
blacks out and goes on instinct and
saves them all as they crash back to the
planet or something else happens you
also notice that they're wearing the
Frank quitely uniforms from new x-men
the new poster that they just released
Ashley has a couple new characters we
don't know who some of these people are
you may notice the visual Easter Egg
here too the Phoenix part of her uniform
looks almost exactly like the Phoenix
uniform from x-men Last Stand so the
other big thing that they talked about
in this interview that Jessica Chastain
was doing on Jimmy Fallon is that she
said you know maybe I get to kill a
couple x-men but I think the whole idea
is is the Jean Grey accidentally kills
one of the x-men and I think we're all
on the same page that its mystique just
based on the travelers because you see a
really early in the
arguing with Professor X when Jean Grey
is a child then getting really pissed
off at him later and then for like the
second half of the trailer where they're
all bummed out after the funeral you
don't see mystique in any of the new
footage so sort of a callback moment
when she accidentally quote-unquote
probably kills her family as a child so
even if Jessica Chastain's character
does get to kill a couple of the x-men
characters I'm guessing they're more
minor characters and mystique is like
the really big death that bums everyone
out but that one's on Jean Grey not on
her so let me know in the comments which
other x-men do you think that they're
gonna kill during this and I'm talking
about major characters because this is
the last Fox x-men film that's not being
done under Marvel Studios I also feel
like the Phoenix coming for this convoy
and just ripping it to shreds is a
parallel meant to be like a cooler
version of the convoy scene from Last
Stand with Magneto the juggernaut and
mystique and talk about callback to all
callbacks going back to the very first
x-men film what is one of the most
iconic trailer moments from the very
first x-men 2000 film with magneto you
see him on the back of this train going
full-blown against the Phoenix trying to
take her down by using all these guns
with his abilities that's a callback
Easter Egg for the Magneto scene from
x-men 2000 when he takes all those
police officers guns and turns them back
on and with his powers so I'm guessing
that just because this is the last x-men
film they tried to include Easter eggs
for all of the other x-men films that
it's done going all the way back to
x-men 2000 so just keep your eyes peeled
when you go see it this summer I'm
wondering how much they changed the end
of this to give it sort of like a final
bookend when they knew that the Disney
Fox deal was gonna go through because
they'd started making this movie before
that happened there was a big delay last
year the movie was supposed to come out
I think it was last November but they
delayed it they did a bunch of reshoots
they probably polished a lot of the
special effects and there's no way that
they did not use the extra opportunity
to just tweak the ending a little bit to
make it a little more final because I'm
sure Kevin Feige is considering keeping
some of these actors on like if McAvoy
or Michael Fassbender want to stick
around
they're huge names and amazing actors
and it would be pretty easy to find a
really comic book explainer for how they
show up in the MCU but they had a big
contract renegotiation around x-men
apocalypse so it was already a big deal
that they were coming back to do this
Dark Phoenix movie so I'm not expecting
them to stick around but all bets are
off wide open to speculation I'm
assuming for now until we hear more
details that Kevin Feige will just
recast all these characters when he
wants to use some of them in the MCU
movies I've already done a couple videos
about the official Marvel phase for a
movie scheduled for the next couple of
years so I'll link one of those videos
at the end of this obviously because of
legal reasons Kevin Feige isn't allowed
to talk about what he wants to do with
the x-men publicly but he did say that
they do have plans and because of all
the Disney Plus streaming shows the
Avenger spin-offs like the Loki TV show
with Tom Hiddleston the Winter Soldier
Falcon TV show The Scarlet Witch
envisioned TV show in addition to all
those Marvel MCU titles that they're
doing on Disney Plus they'll also
eventually be developing x-men
live-action series for that too but
there'll be series that tie into the MCU
and Kevin Feige did explain that they
would take place in the past present and
future of the MCU
so think about it this way you get a
live-action TV show with any x-men
characters you want what do you want
them to do or would you just rather all
the characters show up in the movies
because like the some characters Silver
Surfer Galactus that I think are totally
cool showing up in the space space
movies if they don't want to use them in
a Fantastic Four movie but I wouldn't
plan on seeing any really big MCU x-men
films for at least a couple years after
the deal is done this movie is coming
out before spider-man far from home so
just expect them to announce x-men plans
at Comic Con this summer at the end of
July while you wait for everything click
here for my breakdown of the Marvel
phase 4 movie schedule and click here
for my non-spoilery Captain Marvel
review thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]